مستحيل مستحيل متى استوعبت انه اللي خلفها
ان عمليه ارهابيه ذات طابع فكري يعني او
جهادي طبعا مع العمر انا انا في وقتها
عرفت المعلومه هذه لكن ماني بمستوعب شلون
تجاهد بين مسلمين
وشلون تفجر بمكان كله مكان حكومي موظفين
كلهم سعوديين موظفين دوله جاهد مع مين
واتجاه الضد مين
يعني
واصلا
من الاساسيات في الجهاد انك تاخذ ولي
الامر انت شلون قاعد تجاهد في بلد يحكموا
لامرك وشلون
فبديت استوعب انا متاخر الموضوع هذا
وطبعا هذه يعني يمكن هنا نقدر احنا نقدم
رساله
للجيل الجاي الجيل الجديد
ابغى اتكلم يعني مع الناس اللي اعمارهم
عشرين سنه وتحت بالذات انا ما ابغى اروح
بعيد 2015 قريب ترى من 8 سنين الي عمره 20
سنه كان وقتها عمره 12 سنه صحيح
كيف يفجرون عند المساجد
كنا نصلي الجمعه وكان في شرطه تحمينا عشان
ندخل نصلي الجمعه
والحرم النبوي يقتحموه الحرموه
الموضوع ما خلص الموضوع ما خلص الموضوع
مستمر موضوع مستمر
وترى هذه يعني بعد لازم تفتح عينك وضريتك
على الناس كلها تقرا الان وتشوف
وكل الناس معهم جوالات وبالذات في تويتر
تقعد تتفرج الافكار مختلفه في تويتر
فتلقى مثال ناس يتكلمون
عن جزء من الناس اللي كانوا يسمون مشايخ
وانهم هذولي اعتقلوا بظلم وهكذا وهكذا
وهكذا من بعد يعني من بعد ما اعتقلي هذا
الروس هذول
الوضع الان ترى يعني الحمد لله على الامن
والامان فمعناه ان في علاقه فيهم
معناته في علاقه نعم لا احد يقول لي ما في
علاقه لا في علاقه لو ما في علاقه كانت
استمرت الامور على ما هي عليه لكن
يعني الموضوع واضح وصريح ولازم الواحد يعي
ويستوعب هذا الموضوع
في
في حديث عن الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام
يقول فيه
هناك دعاه على ابواب جهنم اجابهم قذفوه
فيها
ابواب جهنم هذول هم بالضبط